This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. For most of history, there's really only been one way to blow things up. Basically, gunpowder was invented sometime around 800 A.D. and you packed a bunch of gunpowder in as small a location as you could and you set fire to it and blew it up. And that was basically the state of the art for a millennium. That's Stephen Johnson. He writes about science, technology and the history of innovation. And he explained how the second half of the 1800s forever changed how we make explosives.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在人类历史的大部分时间里，引爆物体的方法其实只有一种。基本上，火药是在公元800年左右发明的，你把一堆火药塞进尽可能小的空间里，点火，然后引爆。这就是一千年来最先进的技术。那是斯蒂芬·约翰逊。他撰写关于科学、技术和创新历史的文章。他解释了19世纪下半叶是如何永远改变了我们制造炸药的方式。
First came the discovery of nitroglycerin. Basically this extraordinarily unstable substance that just jostling could cause an explosion. You know, you didn't need to kind of light a match to set it off. You could just shake it and it would blow up in your face. Nitroglycerin was just too volatile to use. It literally blew up in people's faces all the time. And so one scientist named Alfred Nobel wanted to figure out how to create a controlled explosion. Eventually he had upon this idea, which he referred to as the blasting cap, where you
首先是硝化甘油的发现。这是一种极其不稳定的物质，稍微晃动一下就可能引发爆炸。你知道，你不需要点火柴来引爆它。你只要摇晃它，它就会在你脸上爆炸。硝化甘油太不稳定了，无法使用。它确实总是会在人们脸上爆炸。因此，一位名叫阿尔弗雷德·诺贝尔的科学家想弄清楚如何制造可控的爆炸。最终，他想出了一个主意，他称之为雷管，在那里你
would use basically just a little bit of gunpowder to trigger a small little explosion which would then set off the big shockwave explosion of nitroglycerin detonating. However, working with these materials led to lots of unwanted explosions, including one which hit too close to home. There was an accidental explosion at the lab that he had set up on his family's property in Stockholm, and his brother was blown to bits in this explosion. To avoid these premature detonations, Nobel needed to figure out a way to safely work with and transport this compound.
基本上只需要用一点点火药来触发一个小小的爆炸，然后引爆硝化甘油爆炸产生的大冲击波。然而，使用这些材料导致了许多不必要的爆炸，其中一次离家太近了。他在斯德哥尔摩自家房产里建立的实验室发生了意外爆炸，他的兄弟在这场爆炸中被炸得粉身碎骨。为了避免这些过早的引爆，诺贝尔需要想出一种安全地处理和运输这种化合物的方法。
And while tinkering in one of his labs off the river Elbe, he realized that the solution was in the dunes all around him. And eventually he realizes that the sand that is a very specific, unusual kind of sand, if you mix it with nitroglycerin, it forms this paste, and it stabilizes the nitroglycerin, so that if you move it or shake it a little bit, it doesn't explode. He named the product dynamite after the dynamite powder. Basically, he named it after sand.
当他在易北河边的一个实验室里摆弄时，他意识到解决方案就在他周围的沙丘里。最终他意识到，这种沙子是一种非常特殊、不寻常的沙子，如果你把它和硝化甘油混合，它会形成一种糊状物，并稳定硝化甘油，这样如果你移动或摇晃它一点点，它就不会爆炸。他以炸药粉的名字命名了这个产品——炸药（Dynamite）。基本上，他是以沙子的名字命名的。
And dynamite changed the way people were building the infrastructure of the modern world, from sewers to subways to skyscrapers. Those were slow, arduous processes. If you did them with a pickaxe, structure of the modern world, from sewers to subways to skyscrapers. Those were slow, arduous processes. If you did them with a pickaxe, and they were a little bit faster if you did them with a large trove of gunpowder that you could use to explode.
炸药改变了人们建造现代世界基础设施的方式，从下水道到地铁再到摩天大楼。那些是缓慢而艰巨的过程。如果你用镐来做，现代世界的结构，从下水道到地铁再到摩天大楼。那些是缓慢而艰巨的过程。如果你用镐来做，如果你用一大堆可以用来爆炸的火药，它们会快一点。
But if you had this enormously compact and efficient explosive power in the form of canisters of dynamite, you can improve the productivity of canisters of dynamite. You can improve the, and sense the productivity of building out these spaces by blowing them up, you know, by a factor of five or 10. It was an enormous leap forward. That level of destructive power wasn't just intriguing to the civil engineers of the world.
但是，如果你有这种以炸药罐形式存在的极其紧凑和高效的爆炸力，你可以提高炸药罐的生产力。你可以通过炸毁它们来提高建造这些空间的生产力，你知道，提高五到十倍。这是一个巨大的飞跃。这种破坏力不仅对世界各地的土木工程师很有吸引力。
Governments, criminal gangs, and political groups also saw the potential in having the destructive power of an army in the palm of your hand. Dynamite especially caught the attention of New York City's burgeoning anarchist movement in the early 20th century. The anarchists had a lot of different ideas, but for complicated reasons, they fell in to this strategy
政府、犯罪团伙和政治团体也看到了将军队的破坏力掌握在手中的潜力。炸药尤其引起了20世纪初纽约市新兴无政府主义运动的注意。无政府主义者有很多不同的想法，但由于复杂的原因，他们陷入了这种策略
of what we would now call terrorism. You could just literally like carry a stick of dynamite in your coat pocket and walk into a cafe and throw it into the crowd and blow it up. It was portable, it could be concealed very easily, and it was basically a force amplifier. And if you were interested in strategic displays of violence, either targeting wealthy people,
即我们现在所说的恐怖主义。你可以真的像在口袋里装一根炸药，走进咖啡馆，把它扔进人群中引爆。它便于携带，很容易隐藏，而且基本上是一个力量放大器。如果你对战略性的暴力展示感兴趣，无论是针对富人，
people in power, leaders of countries or corporate icons. Dynamite gave you a tool that simply didn't exist before. Steven Johnson's new book is called The Infernal Machine, a true story of dynamite, terror, and the rise of the modern detective. And he tells this story about how the anarchist movement in the U. the US gets wooed by dynamite, forever shaping how we think about making political change.
当权者、国家领导人或企业偶像。炸药为你提供了一种以前根本不存在的工具。斯蒂芬·约翰逊的新书名为《地狱机器：炸药、恐怖和现代侦探的崛起》。他讲述了这个故事，关于美国的无政府主义运动是如何被炸药所吸引，永远地塑造了我们对如何进行政治变革的思考。
In this strange twist of history, Nobel's invention designed for one purpose gets co-opted by a whole different set of people who are intent on a set of objectives that completely go against everything that Nobel was trying to do. And they get locked in this kind of tragic embrace for 40 years. While the anarchists used dynamite to spur chaos against the oppressive state, the police embraced and developed their own technology to combat them. And the police's weapon of choice was surveillance technology. Stephen tells the story of the tension between these two technologies and what we can learn from one of the most explosive periods in American history.
在这个奇怪的历史转折中，诺贝尔为单一目的而设计的发明被一群完全不同的人所利用，他们的目标完全违背了诺贝尔试图做的一切。他们被锁在这种悲剧性的拥抱中长达40年。当无政府主义者利用炸药来煽动对压迫性国家的混乱时，警察拥抱并发展了自己的技术来打击他们。警察选择的武器是监视技术。斯蒂芬讲述了这两种技术之间的紧张关系，以及我们可以从美国历史上最爆炸性的时期中学到什么。
So let's talk about the anarchists. What is it that they believed in? I mean, the contemporary meaning of anarchy that comes to mind, the connotation of it, is negative chaos, right? It was literally the Greek of anarchos, which means like no rulers. But the truth of the matter is that anarchism was a very interesting philosophy at that moment in time, particularly in the middle of the kind of,
那么让我们谈谈无政府主义者。他们信仰什么？我的意思是，人们想到的无政府状态的当代含义，它的内涵是消极的混乱，对吧？它字面上是希腊语的“anarchos”，意思是“没有统治者”。但事实是，无政府主义在当时是一种非常有趣的哲学，特别是在某种程度上，
in early days of the Industrial Revolution, when the body count from the factory system was empirically just much higher than any of the terrorist attacks set off by the anarchists. People were just dying these, like, brutal deaths every single day in factories all around the world. And so, you know, there was this idea that was there in the early days of anarchism
在工业革命的早期，工厂系统造成的死亡人数在经验上确实比无政府主义者发起的任何恐怖袭击都要高得多。世界各地的工厂里，人们每天都在经历这种残酷的死亡。所以，你知道，在无政府主义的早期就有这种想法
that humans had actually lived in much more stable and seemingly sustainable forms in earlier points in history where you had people working and doing technologically advanced work, but they weren't doing it inside of these large corporate systems and they didn't have large armies and they didn't have large governments. They were able to live in a pleasant and productive way of life. And the anarchists were saying, hey, it's not too late to go back to that. Right.
人类实际上在历史的早期阶段生活在更稳定、看似更可持续的形式中，那时人们在工作，从事技术先进的工作，但他们不是在这些大型企业系统内工作，他们没有庞大的军队，也没有庞大的政府。他们能够以一种愉快和富有成效的方式生活。而无政府主义者说，嘿，现在回去还不晚。对。
So they're sort of anti-capitalism and anti-government and in the early 20th century, they used dynamite to get their message across. Yeah, in fact some of the first real kind of terrorist acts, the first suicide bombing, the first civilian terrorist attack, were perpetrated by anarchists in this period and in both those cases and in many other cases, the weapon of choice was dynamite. And by the way, it's worth mentioning, dynamite is so integrated into the worldview
所以他们某种程度上是反资本主义和反政府的，在20世纪初，他们利用炸药来传达他们的信息。是的，事实上，一些最早的真正的恐怖主义行为，第一次自杀式爆炸袭击，第一次平民恐怖袭击，都是由这一时期的无政府主义者实施的，在这两种情况下以及许多其他情况下，选择的武器都是炸药。顺便提一下，值得一提的是，炸药如此融入了无政府主义者的世界观
and political posturing of the anarchists that they're often referred to as the dynamite club. And you'll see just quote after quote from these radicals saying like, you know, we can counter the guns of the state with dynamite. This is our best way to fight back. So the way they justified it was that there was so much more violence at the hands of big government and big capital.
和政治姿态，以至于他们经常被称为“炸药俱乐部”。你会看到这些激进分子引用的一句又一句的话说，你知道，我们可以用炸药来对抗国家的枪支。这是我们反击的最佳方式。所以他们证明其合理性的方式是，大政府和大资本手中存在着更多的暴力。
And you did, in fact, have things like the Ludlow Massacre and other labor strikes that ended in terrible violence, with the perpetrators of the violence largely being Croatians and sometimes assisted by the government. And so how widespread were these bombings at the time? I'm curious how present the threat of bombing was for people in this era. One of the first facts that got me into this project, actually, is there was a guy named Owen Egan.
而且，你确实有像勒德洛大屠杀和其他以可怕暴力告终的劳工罢工这样的事情，暴力的肇事者主要是克罗地亚人，有时在政府的协助下。那么当时这些爆炸事件有多普遍？我很好奇在那个时代，爆炸的威胁对人们来说有多真实。实际上，让我开始这个项目的第一个事实是，有一个叫欧文·伊根的人。
He was technically a fireman, but he worked very closely with the New York Police Department. I think his title was something like Chief of Combustibles or something like that. He was basically the number one and arguably only bomb diffuser and bomb analyst on the staff of the fire department slash NYPD for about 30 years, from about 1896 into the early 20s. He died on the job of indigestion, apparently. He lived this incredibly dangerous life and somehow survived it all. He lost a couple of fingers over those years. But the thing that struck me so early on
他技术上是一名消防员，但他与纽约警察局合作非常密切。我想他的头衔大概是“易燃物主管”之类的。他基本上是消防局/纽约警察局员工中排名第一，也可以说是唯一的炸弹拆除专家和炸弹分析师，工作了大约30年，从1896年左右到20年代初。他显然是在工作中死于消化不良。他过着极其危险的生活，却不知何故幸存了下来。这些年来他失去了几根手指。但让我很早就感到震惊的是
was that over those 30 years, Owen Egan either diffused or analyzed the wreckage from over 7,000 bombs in New York City. And some of those bombs were actually mob related. It was basically a mechanism for extortion So if you didn't pay up, you know they would put a small bomb in front of your storefront and just show you that you know, you had to obey the local mafia, but a number of them were political and
在过去的30年里，欧文·伊根拆除或分析了纽约市7000多枚炸弹的残骸。其中一些炸弹实际上与黑帮有关。这基本上是一种勒索机制。所以如果你不付钱，你知道，他们会在你的店面放一个小炸弹，只是向你展示，你知道，你必须服从当地的黑手党，但其中一些是政治性的，
Having lived in New York City most my life having lived through 9-eleven I just tried to imagine what it would have been like to be through 9-11. I just tried to imagine what it would have been like to be living in New York City in a period where over three decades 7,000 bombs had gone off. I spent so much time in the kind of newspaper archives and almost, you know, you just pick a random edition of a New York paper from that period and look at the front page and like it's pretty likely there'll be a mention of a bomb going off somewhere. I mean just statistically it was just happening all the time. And how much of this destruction was tied to the anarchists in the public mind? Like how looming a threat was the anarchist movement?
我一生大部分时间都住在纽约市，经历过9/11事件，我只是试着想象生活在那个时期会是什么样子。我只是试着想象生活在纽约市，在那个时期，三年来发生了7000多起爆炸事件。我花了很多时间在报纸档案里，几乎，你知道，你随便挑一份那个时期的纽约报纸，看看头版，很可能会提到某个地方发生了爆炸。我的意思是，从统计学上讲，它一直在发生。那么在公众心目中，这种破坏有多少与无政府主义者有关？无政府主义运动的威胁有多大？
Yeah, a lot of it was. There is a kind of a blurring of lines between the socialists and the communists and the IWW and the anarchists and they were, you know, bedfellows and in some ways and in some ways not, largely disagreeing about the role of the state. Right. They were equally opposed to big capitalism, but the anarchists also felt that big government was as much of a problem. So there was a general sense of radicals were causing this political violence. Right. And one of those radicals that you talk about in the book is Emma Goldman.
是的，很大一部分是。社会主义者、共产主义者、世界产业工人联合会（IWW）和无政府主义者之间的界限有些模糊，他们在某些方面是同床异梦，在某些方面又不是，主要是在国家的作用上存在分歧。对。他们同样反对大资本主义，但无政府主义者也认为大政府同样是个问题。所以人们普遍认为激进分子正在造成这种政治暴力。对。你在书中谈到的那些激进分子之一是艾玛·戈德曼。
Could you tell me about her and what her role in the anarchist movement was? Emma Goldman, you know, is one of the most endlessly fascinating figures of this period. A Russian emigre came over without much actual education, came over as a teenager to the United States, somehow was giving lectures on radical politics within a couple of years of her arrival here, became the leading figure of the anarchist movement, arguably worldwide by the first decades of the 20th century, and had a very complicated relationship to political violence. She had had this long time partnership, really what turned out to be a lifelong partnership,
你能告诉我关于她以及她在无政府主义运动中的角色吗？艾玛·戈德曼，你知道，是这一时期最令人着迷的人物之一。一位俄罗斯移民，没有受过多少正规教育，十几岁时来到美国，几年内就开始就激进政治发表演讲，到20世纪头几十年，可以说成为全球无政府主义运动的领军人物，并且与政治暴力有着非常复杂的关系。她有着长期的伙伴关系，实际上后来变成了终身的伙伴关系，
with Alexander Berkman, who had a much less complicated relationship to political violence, and had notoriously attempted to assassinate Henry Clay Frick in the early 1890s, gone to prison for more than a decade. But those early experiences, which Goldman had been largely supportive of, had kind of turned her against the use of political violence in in her writings in her public statements this is right around the time that Gandhi is
与亚历山大·伯克曼（Alexander Berkman）在一起，他对政治暴力的关系要简单得多，并且臭名昭著地试图在19世纪90年代初暗杀亨利·克莱·弗里克（Henry Clay Frick），并入狱十多年。但那些早期的经历，戈德曼在很大程度上是支持的，在某种程度上使她在她的著作和公开声明中反对使用政治暴力，这正好是甘地正在
Kind of formalizing the principles of nonviolent protest and if if Goldman had really in a full-throated way Embraced those or had hit upon them independently the whole history of the anarchist movement might have played out differently Right since the anarchists did not opt for nonviolent protest, what happened next? And how did they essentially become public enemy number one? So after McKinley is assassinated by an anarchist in 1901, and a complicated set of events,
某种程度上将非暴力抗议原则形式化的时候，如果戈德曼真的以一种完全彻底的方式拥抱了这些原则，或者独立地想到了它们，无政府主义运动的整个历史可能会有不同的发展。对。既然无政府主义者没有选择非暴力抗议，接下来发生了什么？他们是如何基本上成为头号公敌的？所以在1901年麦金莱被一名无政府主义者暗杀后，在一系列复杂的事件中，
Goldman is incorrectly blamed for it, Teddy Roosevelt ascends to the presidency, and he delivers a speech and basically the speech is saying that the number one threat in the world is anarchism. He refers to the anarchist as the enemy of all mankind. But just the idea that the President of the United States would address Congress and say this is our biggest problem right now is fighting the anarchist threat. That tells you just how significant it was at that moment in time.
戈德曼被错误地指责，西奥多·罗斯福登上了总统宝座，他发表了一次演讲，基本上演讲的内容是说世界上头号威胁是无政府主义。他称无政府主义者为全人类的敌人。但仅仅是美国总统向国会发表讲话并说这是我们现在面临的最大问题，即打击无政府主义威胁。这告诉你它在当时有多么重要。
fighting the anarchist threat. That tells you just how significant it was at that moment in time. Wow, so anarchism and these bomb plots are really front of mind for much of the country. And one of the most dramatic parts of the book is an anarchist bomb plot where the bombs were sent in the mail. Could you tell me that story? So you have this period in the first two decades
打击无政府主义威胁。这告诉你它在当时有多么重要。哇，所以无政府主义和这些炸弹阴谋确实是全国大部分地区最关心的问题。书中戏剧性的部分之一是一个无政府主义炸弹阴谋，炸弹是通过邮件发送的。你能告诉我那个故事吗？所以你有这个时期，在头二十年
of the 20th century where these bombings just increase in regularity in the United States. It the 20th century, where these bombings just increase in regularity in the United States. It kind of swept across Europe. And then they come to the United States and really are concentrated initially in New York. And then they start spreading across the rest of the country.
20世纪，这些爆炸事件在美国的发生频率不断增加。它席卷了欧洲。然后它们来到美国，最初确实集中在纽约。然后它们开始蔓延到全国其他地区。
And one of the most extraordinary events that happens in the spring of 1919 is a series of bombing attacks, male bombing attacks, that begin with a bombing in Seattle, an attempted bombing in Seattle, that is accidentally foiled, basically. The package is opened upside down, and so the bomb doesn't go off. And then the next day, a package is opened at the home of a Georgia senator by his wife and a servant.
1919年春天发生的最非凡的事件之一是一系列爆炸袭击，邮件爆炸袭击，始于西雅图的一次爆炸，西雅图的一次未遂爆炸，基本上是意外被挫败的。包裹被倒着打开了，所以炸弹没有爆炸。第二天，一位佐治亚州参议员的妻子和一名仆人在家中打开了一个包裹。
And that does explode. The servant loses both of her hands and the wife is injured in this. The senator isn't home at the point. And the news reports mention that the package had a very distinctive kind of marking and was wrapped from Gimbels, the department store. And that night, a postal clerk in New York is riding the subway home at midnight from his kind of late shift at the post office. And he happens to read a story about these mail bombs.
那确实爆炸了。仆人失去了双手，妻子也因此受伤。参议员当时不在家。新闻报道提到，包裹有一个非常独特的标记，是从金贝尔百货公司（Gimbels）包装的。那天晚上，纽约的一名邮政职员在午夜从邮局的晚班下班，乘地铁回家。他碰巧读到了一篇关于这些邮件炸弹的报道。
And he realizes that he has seen that exact wrapping in the main central post office in New York. In fact, he has seen 16 identical packages with that exact wrapping. And what's happened basically is that the packages had been sent out by anarchists, but they had slightly messed up the postage. And so there was some question about whether,
他意识到他在纽约中央邮局见过那种包装。事实上，他见过16个带有那种包装的相同包裹。基本上发生的事情是，这些包裹是由无政府主义者寄出的，但他们稍微弄错了邮资。所以关于是否，
I think it's just something about it being a kind of a novelty item And so there was some question about whether, I think it's something about it being a kind of a novelty item, and there was some question whether you got this cheaper postage rate with novelty items as opposed to other things. And so this clerk had put the packages aside, all 16 of them, and was waiting for his superior to basically deliver a ruling whether these things had to be sent back or not. So this postal clerk who notices these 16 identical packages, what does he end up doing? He realizes that, you know, he potentially these bombs are just sitting down there at the post office.
我想这只是关于它是一种新奇物品，所以关于是否，我想这只是关于它是一种新奇物品，关于你是否能用新奇物品获得这种更便宜的邮资费率，而不是其他东西。所以这名职员把这些包裹放在一边，所有16个，并等待他的上级基本上做出裁决，这些东西是否必须退回。那么这个注意到这16个相同包裹的邮政职员，他最后做了什么？他意识到，你知道，他可能这些炸弹就放在邮局下面。
And so he jumps off the train, goes all the way back down to 34th Street, calls in his boss, they identify the packages and say that, yeah, these do fit the description. And so then they call Owen Egan, chief of combustibles, and he goes in and diffuses one of these bombs. And the whole plot is largely avoided. And so it's one of these things where literally, I mean, on some level, like the course of American political history could have been changed. If they had just decided to, you know, spend an extra like 10 cents on the postage for these bombs that they were sending out. When we come back, Steven Johnson tells us about how the state tried to organize and contain the chaos. Okay, so we're in these decades where the anarchist movement is really active. There are these bombs going off all over the city, and there's this real fear of the anarchist
所以他跳下火车，一路回到第34街，叫来他的老板，他们确认了包裹并说，是的，这些确实符合描述。然后他们叫来了易燃物主管欧文·伊根，他进去拆除了其中一枚炸弹。整个阴谋在很大程度上被避免了。所以这是那种事情之一，字面上，我的意思是，在某种程度上，美国政治历史的进程可能会被改变。如果他们只是决定，你知道，在他们寄出的这些炸弹上多花10美分邮资的话。当我们回来时，斯蒂芬·约翰逊将告诉我们国家是如何试图组织和遏制这种混乱的。好的，所以我们正处于无政府主义运动非常活跃的几十年里。城市各处都在发生爆炸，人们对无政府主义确实感到真正的恐惧
movement and what these so-called radicals can do. And at the same time all this is going on, you've got the police and the government trying to figure out how to regain some kind of control of the situation. But they don't exactly have the tools to do it. Could you tell me more about this? So up until the late 1880s, the idea of true detective work being done with scientific tools,
运动以及这些所谓的激进分子能做什么。与此同时，所有这些都在进行，警察和政府正试图弄清楚如何重新获得某种对局势的控制。但他们并没有完全具备这样做的工具。你能告诉我更多关于这个的信息吗？所以直到19世纪80年代末，用科学工具进行真正侦探工作的想法，
like for instance, fingerprint science, and done in a formal way with complex records, histories of people convicted of crimes, identification systems including fingerprints. All that stuff just didn't exist. And crucially, this is another thing that I think is so important to this story, there was really no federal investigative force. There was no FBI.
例如，指纹科学，并以正式的方式进行，有复杂的记录、犯罪定罪者的历史、包括指纹在内的识别系统。所有这些东西根本不存在。至关重要的是，这是我认为对这个故事非常重要的另一件事，确实没有联邦调查力量。没有联邦调查局（FBI）。
There was a Bureau of Investigation that was chronically kind of underfunded. There had generally been a suspicion, kind of an old-school American suspicion, of consolidating too much power, particularly kind of investigative power, in the federal government. If you were charged with a federal crime, like you could be charged with a crime, but it was very hard to prove it because there was no system, there were no people on payroll, basically, who could kind of marshal the evidence together to prove that you were guilty. But soon, fingerprint science develops alongside all these other technologies that we'd call
有一个调查局，资金长期不足。人们普遍有一种怀疑，一种老派的美国式怀疑，即权力过于集中，特别是联邦政府的调查权力。如果你被指控犯有联邦罪行，比如你可能被指控犯罪，但很难证明，因为没有系统，没有在职人员，基本上，可以把证据汇总起来证明你有罪。但很快，指纹科学与我们今天所说的所有其他技术一起发展起来
biometrics today. Yeah, and because there was no national institution in the United States to use these new advances in confronting the threat of anarchism, The real pioneers in adopting these new techniques happened on a city level and particularly happened in New York. And so how did the police start using these new tools and techniques? Yeah, New York between 1900 and 1920 really reinvents itself as a state-of-the-art police department led by a few people like Joseph Ferro and Arthur Woods,
生物识别技术。是的，因为美国没有国家机构来利用这些新进展来对抗无政府主义的威胁，采用这些新技术真正的先驱发生在城市层面，特别是在纽约。那么警察是如何开始使用这些新工具和技术的呢？是的，1900年到1920年间的纽约确实将自己重塑为一个最先进的警察部门，由约瑟夫·费罗（Joseph Ferro）和亚瑟·伍兹（Arthur Woods）等少数人领导，
who adopt these new tools. In many cases, they travel over to Europe to kind of find out about them and come back. And, you know, one of the things that I think is just so extraordinary is the basic lack of identification systems. Throughout the 19th century, like, people didn't largely have passports or driver's licenses or obviously or any kind of biometric evidence for who they were. So if you were arrested for a crime, you could just say they'd be like, what's your name? And you could say, my name is Bill Jones. And there was on some level, there's no way to prove that you were not Bill Jones, even if you've just been arrested three days ago under another name. And so just the basic ability to capture people's identity and prove that they
他们采用了这些新工具。在许多情况下，他们前往欧洲了解这些工具，然后回来。而且，你知道，我认为非常非凡的事情之一是识别系统的基本缺乏。在整个19世纪，人们大多没有护照或驾照，显然也没有任何关于他们是谁的生物识别证据。所以如果你因犯罪被捕，你可以随便说，他们会问，你叫什么名字？你可以说，我叫比尔·琼斯。在某种程度上，没有办法证明你不是比尔·琼斯，即使你三天前刚以另一个名字被捕。所以仅仅是捕捉人们身份并证明他们
were that person. And that they were the person who had been convicted of a crime or suspected of a crime two years ago or five years ago was an enormous leap forward. And biometrics and fingerprinting and photography and all that really introduced that. And the power of something like fingerprint technology takes a little while to gain popularity. And there's this incredible court case that you read about
是那个人。而且他们是两年前或五年前被定罪或被怀疑犯罪的人，这是一个巨大的飞跃。生物识别技术、指纹识别、摄影等等确实引入了这一点。指纹技术的某种力量需要一段时间才能流行起来。你读到过一个令人难以置信的法庭案件
that really shepherds in this era of forensic science. Could you tell us that story? Yeah, it's a case against a burglar named Charles Crispy who had broken into a Soho loft and stolen some, I believe, undergarments. I think it was kind of a ladies' undergarment store. And he left behind a fingerprint and it matched a previous fingerprint
这确实引领了法医科学的时代。你能给我们讲讲那个故事吗？是的，这是一个针对名叫查尔斯·克里斯皮（Charles Crispy）的窃贼的案件，他闯入了一个苏豪区的阁楼，偷了一些，我相信是内衣。我想那是一家女士内衣店。他留下了一个指纹，它与之前的指纹相匹配
and the fingerprint evidence was really central to the case, but no one had ever been successfully convicted of a crime based on fingerprint evidence before that. So what does Fereau end up doing? Fereau, who has kind of built up this against a lot of resistance internally at the NYPD, he's built up this small identification bureau and he's pretty much the fingerprint guy inside the NYPD.
指纹证据确实是案件的核心，但在那之前，从来没有人因为指纹证据而被成功定罪。那么费罗最后做了什么？费罗，他在纽约警察局内部的巨大阻力下建立了这个小型识别局，他几乎是纽约警察局内部的指纹专家。
This is like 1911. And he is called in as pretty much the only witness for the prosecution because they really don't have any other evidence other than this fingerprint. And so Ferro is testifying and he's asked to explain his method witness for the prosecution because they really don't have any other evidence other than this fingerprint and so froze is Testifying and he's asked to explain his method and he just like rolls out this crazy explanation that clearly just bombs in the room So what is the prosecution do that? So they come back and they basically are like we'd like to do an experiment we'd like to do a demo in a sense of this technology for the jury so that
这大概是1911年。他被传唤作为控方的几乎唯一证人，因为除了这个指纹，他们真的没有任何其他证据。所以费罗正在作证，他被要求解释他的方法，作为控方的证人，因为除了这个指纹，他们真的没有任何其他证据，所以费罗正在作证，他被要求解释他的方法，他只是像滚雪球一样抛出了一个疯狂的解释，显然在房间里搞砸了。那么控方对此做了什么？所以他们回来，基本上他们说，我们想做一个实验，我们想为陪审团做一个这种技术的演示，这样
they can understand it. And they basically have Farrow leave the room and the jurors come through and one of the jurors presses his finger against a pane of glass simulating what Charles Crispi, the accused criminal, had done. And then all the other jurors, including the one who pressed his finger on the glass, do a traditional fingerprint impression. And they bring Ferro back, and then Ferro is basically seated in front of the jury and he has to identify which juror has put their finger on the glass and he nails it.
他们可以理解它。他们基本上让费罗离开房间，陪审员们走过来，其中一名陪审员将手指按在玻璃板上，模拟查尔斯·克里斯皮（被指控的罪犯）所做的事情。然后所有其他陪审员，包括那个把手指按在玻璃上的陪审员，都做了传统的指纹印记。他们把费罗带回来，然后费罗基本上坐在陪审团面前，他必须识别出哪个陪审员把手指放在了玻璃上，他做到了。
He goes through and he picks it out and he's like, it's this juror right here. And the juror is like, what is this witchcraft? You know, like just blown away. It is just a credible display of his scientific power. And almost instantly, Crispy changes his plea to guilty. He just sees the fire, the scientific firepower that's off against him and he gives in.
他走过去，把它挑出来，他说，就是这个陪审员。陪审员说，这是什么巫术？你知道，简直被震撼了。这简直是对他科学力量的令人难以置信的展示。几乎立刻，克里斯皮就改口认罪了。他看到了针对他的科学火力，他屈服了。
Right, because before this, someone who committed a crime could really just essentially disappear. Like an anarchist could throw a stick of dynamite into a church or something and then disappear into the crowd. But the advent of these new technologies really takes away that anonymity. Yeah, and so the tide starts to turn inside the NYPD
对，因为在此之前，犯罪的人真的可以基本上消失。就像一个无政府主义者可以把一根炸药扔进教堂之类的，然后消失在人群中。但这些新技术的出现确实消除了这种匿名性。是的，所以纽约警察局内部的潮流开始转变
and then this Arthur Woods figure becomes commissioner, who's very interested in these things. They build up the information architecture that allows them to kind of track criminals, and they increasingly are using that to investigate the anarchists and other political attacks in New York in that period. And that infrastructure then becomes
然后这个亚瑟·伍兹（Arthur Woods）成为了局长，他对这些事情非常感兴趣。他们建立了信息架构，使他们能够追踪罪犯，并且他们越来越多地利用这一点来调查那一时期纽约的无政府主义者和其他政治袭击。而这种基础设施随后成为了
the basis of what leads to the consolidation of this kind of investigatory power on a federal level. And as the police departments and the federal government are gathering all this information, they need a way to organize all of it. And this is where another key historical figure comes into the picture, and that's J. Edgar Hoover. Could you tell me about Hoover's contribution here
导致这种调查权力在联邦层面整合的基础。随着警察部门和联邦政府收集所有这些信息，他们需要一种方法来组织所有这些信息。这就是另一个关键历史人物出现的地方，那就是J·埃德加·胡佛（J. Edgar Hoover）。你能告诉我胡佛在这里的贡献吗
and how this all collides with the history of the anarchists? Yeah, Hoover had basically moonlit in D.C. when he was in high school and in college as a library clerk. And he was organizing, helping to organize the Library of Congress's voluminous collections. And there had been a new system that had been introduced around this period by the former director of the Library of Congress, whose name was Putnam. And Putnam had introduced something similar to the Dewey Decimal System. It was basically like, hey, we have all these books and they're in different categories and they have authors, so we'll figure out a systematic way of taking this information so that you can explore, it was really on some level like what
以及这一切是如何与无政府主义者的历史发生碰撞的？是的，胡佛在高中和大学时基本上在华盛顿特区兼职做图书馆职员。他正在组织，帮助组织国会图书馆庞大的藏书。在这个时期左右，国会图书馆的前馆长普特南（Putnam）引入了一个新系统。普特南引入了一些类似于杜威十进制分类法的东西。它基本上是，嘿，我们有所有这些书，它们属于不同的类别，它们有作者，所以我们将找出一种系统的方法来获取这些信息，以便你可以探索，它在某种程度上确实像我们
we would now call a search algorithm. He then goes to work for the Justice Department and it's, you know, World War I is still evolving, the United States is not yet involved in the war, but countries moving in that direction and there's serious concern about German nationals inside of the United States who are also actually setting off bombs on their own during this period. And there's serious concern about German nationals inside of the United States, who are also actually setting off bombs on their own during this period. And so Hoover gets assigned to run the New York branch of the big push to register all the German nationals living in the United States, which is arguably like the largest kind of
现在所说的搜索算法。然后他去司法部工作，你知道，第一次世界大战仍在演变，美国尚未卷入战争，但国家正朝着那个方向发展，人们非常担心美国境内的德国国民，他们在此期间实际上也在自己引爆炸弹。人们非常担心美国境内的德国国民，他们在此期间实际上也在自己引爆炸弹。所以胡佛被指派负责纽约分部，推动登记所有居住在美国的德国国民，这可以说是美国历史上最大规模的
identification management roundup in United States history at that point. And Hoover's really good at it. He's something like 23 or 24. And he, you know, wins the praise of his superiors. And so shortly after that, after these bombs are starting to go off in 1918 and 1919, the Bureau of Investigation opens up a new division called the Radical Division. And the Radical Division is going to be charged with rounding up these dangerous anarchists and communists that are setting off these bombs all across the country using these new
身份管理围捕。胡佛真的很擅长。他大概23或24岁。他，你知道，赢得了上级的赞扬。所以在那之后不久，在1918年和1919年这些炸弹开始爆炸后，调查局开设了一个新的部门，名为“激进部门”（Radical Division）。激进部门将负责利用这些新的最先进的信息科学、打击犯罪技术，围捕全国各地引爆炸弹的危险无政府主义者和共产主义者。他们让J·埃德加·胡佛负责激进部门。胡佛的第一个指导任务是利用这种新的信息科学，确保艾玛·戈德曼被驱逐出美利坚合众国。她和伯克曼因鼓励抗拒征兵而被送进监狱，导致了第一次世界大战。所以在这个时期，戈德曼已经从监狱释放，但国内的情绪在很大程度上转向了反对这些激进分子，发生了无休止的爆炸运动。还有很多。所以胡佛，在他作为
state-of-the-art information science, crime-fighting techniques. And they put J. Edgar Hoover in charge of the Radical Division. And Hoover's first guiding quest is to use this new information science to see that Emma Goldman is deported from the United States of America. She and Berkman had been sent to jail for encouraging draft resistance, leading up into World War I. So in this period, Goldman has been released from prison, but the mood in the country is very much kind of turning against these radicals, the kind of endless bombing campaigns that have happened. There have been many more. And so Hoover, in really his first act as
激进部门负责人的第一个行动中，收集了关于戈德曼和亚历山大·伯克曼的大量信息。我浏览过所有这些文件，信息量之大简直令人难以置信，基本上是一整本书，关于她发表的演讲。他系统地组织了这一切，他注释了一切。这正是联邦政府以前根本无法做到的那种信息收集和管理。这是一个以前根本无法提出的案件。胡佛第一次
head of the Radical Division, collects just an enormous amount of information on Goldman and on Alexander Berkman. Just going through, I've seen all these files and it's just extraordinary how much, it's a whole book basically of information, of speeches she'd given. And he's organized it all systematically, he's kind of annotated everything. And it's precisely the kind of information gathering and management that the federal government just had been incapable of doing before. It's just a case that could not have been made before. And Hoover for the first time has kind of
汇总了所有这些信息。所以有一个非常紧张的时刻，埃利斯岛举行了驱逐听证会，戈德曼在那里，胡佛出现了，戈德曼看过去，胡佛的桌子上堆满了纸。这是他汇总的所有证据，最终证明艾玛·戈德曼需要永远离开这个国家。
marshaled all this information. And so there's a kind of really intense moment where there's a deportation hearing on Ellis Island and Goldman is there and Hoover shows up and Goldman looks over, and Hoover just has these stacks of paper on his desk. And it's all the evidence that he's put together to finally make the case that Emma Goldman needs to leave the country for good.
她看过去，对自己说，我无法对抗这个。她看过去，对自己说，我无法对抗这个。所以胡佛最终成功地将她和伯克曼以及其他一些激进分子驱逐出境。他们在1919年的最后几天乘坐一艘媒体戏称为“红色方舟”（Red Ark）的船离开。他们驶出纽约港
And she kind of looks over there and she says to herself, I'm not going to be able to fight this. She kind of looks over there and she says to herself, I'm not gonna be able to fight this. So Hoover ends up successfully deporting her and Berkman along with a number of other radicals. They leave in one of the last days of 1919 aboard a ship that the press dubbed the Red Ark. And they sail out through the New York Harbor
最终到达列宁主义的俄罗斯，在那里他们立刻对那里发生的一切感到幻灭。有趣的是，整个故事是在这两种设计的背景下发生的，它们朝着相反的方向工作。如果你把它们简化为最基本的概念，炸药是制造混乱的破坏力，
and end up in Leninist Russia, where they are instantly disillusioned with everything that is happening there. It's interesting that this whole story is taking place in the backdrop of these two designs, which work in opposite directions. Like if you simplify them to their most basic concepts, dynamite is this destructive power that creates chaos,
而信息科学基本上是在试图整理一切，把一切重新组合在一起。最终，你看到的是一系列事件，炸药为无政府主义运动增压，这导致了法医科学的增压，最终扑灭了无政府主义运动。然后监视国家崛起，它拥有自己破坏性和有害的力量。嗯，我认为其中一件事是我花了多长时间才以那种方式看待它。但它们在某种程度上是隐形的，我想，你知道，不要太品牌化，我不知道，就像随着时间推移缓慢形成的各种技术或方法或设计之间的高层冲突。是的。
and information science is basically trying to order everything, to put everything back together. And ultimately, what you see is this sequence of events where dynamite supercharges the anarchist movement, which leads to the supercharging of the forensic sciences, and that ultimately snuffs out the anarchist movement. And then the surveillance state ascends and it has its own destructive and pernicious power. Well, I think one of the things is how long it took me to see it that way. But they were kind of invisible, I think, you know, not to be too on brand here, I don't know, like high level clash between technologies or approaches or designs that come into being slowly over time. Yeah.
这几乎就像一部非常慢动作的电影，当你以那种慢速观看时，似乎什么都没有发生。当你观察40年时，似乎只是发生了孤立的小事情。但当你加速它时，你意识到，哦，这确实是这两种不同力量之间的碰撞。但一旦你以那种方式看待它，它就非常有启发性。史蒂夫·约翰逊，非常感谢你来到《99%隐形》。和你交谈真是太愉快了。哦，罗曼，我喜欢这个节目，能参加真是太荣幸了。
It's almost like a very slow motion film that nothing seems to be happening when you watch it at that at that slow speed. When you're watching it over like 40 years, it seems like there's just little isolated things happening. But then when you speed it up, you realize, oh, this is really a crash between these two different forces. But once you see it that way, it is very illuminating. Steve Johnson, thank you so much for being on 99% of this. It was a real pleasure to talk to you. Oh, Roman, I love the show and it's such an honor to be on it.
斯蒂芬·约翰逊的新书名为《地狱机器：炸药、恐怖和现代侦探的崛起》。你可以在我们的节目说明中找到这本书的链接，你也可以去商店或上网购买每一本斯蒂芬·约翰逊的书，因为它们都太棒了。《99%隐形》本周由雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳（Jacob Maldonado Medina）制作，尼娜·波图克（Nina Potuck）编辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzalez）混音，斯旺·里尔（Swan Real）配乐。卡莉·图（Cally Too）是我们的执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯塔德（Kurt Kolstad）是数字总监，德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是我们的高级编辑，泰勒·谢德里克（Taylor Shedrick）是我们的实习生。
Stephen Johnson's new book is called The Infernal Machine, a true story of dynamite, terror and the rise of the modern detective. You can find a link to the book in our show notes and you can also just go to a store or go online and just buy every Stephen Johnson book because they're all so, so good. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Jacob Maldonado Medina and edited by Nina Potuck, mixed by Martin Gonzalez, music by Swan Real. Cally Too is our executive producer, Kurt Kolstad is the digital director, Delaney Hall is our senior editor, Taylor Shedrick is our intern.
团队的其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁佩（Chris Berrupe）、杰森·德里昂（Jason DeLeon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、薇薇安·雷（Vivian Ley）、拉什马·唐（Lashma Don）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼（Gabriella Gladney）、凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）和我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。《99%隐形》的标志是由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作的。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大厦。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。奥克兰根足球俱乐部（Oakland Roots Soccer Club）的所在地，我是该俱乐部的骄傲社区所有者。
The rest of the team includes Chris Berrupe, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Ley, Lashma Don, Joe Rosenberg, Gabriella Gladney, Kelly Prime, and me Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California. Home of the Oakland Roots Soccer Club, of which I am a proud community owner.
其他球队可能会来来去去，但根队永远是奥克兰第一。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及我们全新的Discord服务器上找到我们。那里有大约5000个美丽的极客在谈论建筑，谈论《权力掮客》，谈论各种各样的事情。在99PI.org上有一个链接，以及《99PI》的每一集往期节目。这一集的转录还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Other teams may come and go, but the Roots are Oakland first, always. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our brand new Discord server. There's like 5,000 beautiful nerds there talking about architecture, talking about the power broker, talking about all kinds of things. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
其他球队可能会来来去去，但Roots永远首先属于奥克兰。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站上找到我们，也可以加入我们全新的Discord服务器。那里有大约5000名可爱的极客在讨论建筑、权力掮客以及各种各样的话题。你可以在99PI.org找到该服务器的链接以及99PI往期的所有节目。本集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。